hey guys justin here with a gamespot news update new images and videos have recently surfaced online showing off previously unannounced fighters for super smash brothers on Wii U and 3ds spoiler alert while there's a possibility that these are elaborate fakes the videos lend definite credibility to the leaks there is an image of the entire roster revealing new characters to the series including the dog from duck hunt Bowser jr. and schulke from Xenoblade several characters are returning to the game that haven't been officially announced yet including ness rob and mr. game & watch several other images of the game have also appeared and show off different trophies events and minigames when reached for comment a Nintendo of America representative said we have nothing to announce at this time Nintendo will also be live-streaming a shocking announcement tomorrow at six a.m. pacific standard time and we'll be covering it here on gamespot com